cosa manca domanda cosa manca la opere
avremo di quest'oggi come essere in
contatto attraverso la voce non esistono
voci qui anche se magari quasi a luce si
può dar fastidio all'udito ma non
esistono così brutta
esistono voce raccontata prima inizia
che noi siamo gli unici sul pianeta a
parlare siamo gli unici esseri umani
dotati di voce se pensate quella voce
certe cose meravigliose hanno trascinato
milioni di persone martin luther king
hitler
chiunque utilizzando la voce ha
trascinato milioni di persone
e cosa facciamo secondarie contatto
possiamo creare destatis
immaginate se io dicessi un semplice
continuo ok posso dire mille modi
diversi a seconda se voglio avvicinarmi
o allontanati lavori
immaginiamo che arriva il cambio alla
riunione e dice buongiorno distanza
immaginiamo di dire un giorno avrò
persona cara capita come in base
all'utilizzo della voce più potente a
nostra disposizione
cosa possiamo avvicinare possiamo
allontanare
immaginate se i vostri sul parquet sito
tutti oggi rimanere sulla voce cosa
sarebbe stato se ci saranno per fortuna
non è così
la voce noi possiamo parlare di rim
frutta ducati ognuno di noi
locale gli improntati catepol cosa che
definisce in maniera univoca la nostra
voce
la identifica ognuno di noi ha voce per
quello che dicevano resisto voce brutte
e si sono cuciti non educate e un
allenamento costante così come a destra
così come faccio tantissime attività
allo stesso modo dovremmo allenare la
voce sappiamo tutti che abbiamo vissuto
questo momento di anemia fortunato e le
persone hanno prodotto contenuti
probabilmente noi qui abbiamo prodotto
contenuti contenuti ricchi di qualsiasi
tipo perché perché volevamo qualcuno
l'ha detto già prima di pezzi essere in
contatto con altre persone nella nostra
casa nella nostra stanza il nostro
studio aveva uno smartphone
avevamo tutti i mezzi a nostra
disposizione e abbiamo creato con the
beat i contenuti che poi avevo
pubblicato in rete
a prescindere dalla qualità dei
contenuti non mi interessa cibi caldi
adesso ma abbiamo creato le botte di
vite che perché volevamo restare in
contatto persone vogliamo avvicinare le
persone noi e non alle persone
quindi cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo creato
occasioni le faccia prima una mania però
una grande mia c'è stato un aumento di
clienti e hanno creato detenuti e
persone che hanno influito dei contenuti
audio in questo caso c'è stato club
house quanti voi dello scontro mouse al
romano ok ispettori mente si ok c'è
stato cataloghi proporre baus c'è stato
e ha enfatizzato riconoscono il ruolo
della voce messo al centro della
comunicazione tra le persone la voce
senza sovrastrutture
la voce solo e unicamente voce
poi ci sono stati tutti gli altri social
network facebook instagram twitter e
contatto che stanno lavorando quindi ci
hanno fatto altre solo uscendo per
creare delle convinti che ripercorre
quali si possa parlare con la voce
se ci pensate la comunicazione orale è
una di terribile che l'uomo conosciuto e
oggi ci si sta riscoprendo si sta
rimettendo al centro di tutto vivo con
la voce
proviamo ad approfondire la questione
le narrazioni e le storie quella biblica
lavorino alla produzione di contenuti
abbiamo prodotto competitivo e qualcosa
ma è un prodotto con i temi di per qui
parliamo delle narrazioni per
avvicinarci agli altri pratico il senso
di un legame che ero neve nella forza un
legale che gli altri e abbiamo creato
delle storie rinascita di un senso alle
cose
se ci pensate prima le storie le
narrazioni quelle che fino a loro
preistoria conosciamo sono venute a
morena sono state fatte attraverso la
tradizionale no non c'erano i video
cominciamo di telefono c'è una voce le
persone raccontavano ad altre persone
attraverso la voce e il successo sempre
nel corso della storia
poi con la tecnologia abbiamo capito che
è possibile preso la transmedialità cioè
l'utilizzo di più mezzi inclinazione e
siamo trasmettere a chiunque in
qualunque punto del mondo e il nostro
messaggio giusto o sbagliato che sia non
importa in questo caso di dire
ma possiamo trasformare trasferire in
questo messaggio può tornare all'origine
se ci pensate
sono passati 3 mila anni e abbiamo
riscoperto e possiamo raccontare le cose
attraverso la voce io sono qui oggi i
colleghi e vi sto raccontando cose
attraverso soprattutto la voce
oltre poi utilizzo di supporti digitali
se io dovessi fare una domanda perché
spesso si fa ma audio video che
coinvolge di più se volessi fare farvi
questa domanda voi cosa rispondereste
audio video aggiungono quelli che sono a
favore della polio ok abbassate alzate a
quelli del video aspettavo una cosa
diversa se avete già capito
avevo pensato a questa idea ma si è
quasi mai vi racconto di un esperimento
un esperimento che anche su mac
lui mi lamenti questo esperimento fatto
in america è stato condotto su 100
partecipanti 100 partecipanti che a cui
so se ne fa ridere
otto opere di fiction i quattro c'erano
i parenti
quindi in poche abbracciare tutti i
gusti le stesse scene sono state fatte
vedere in formato video quindi le scene
originali di questi film di queste 16 e
sono stati vacas montare informato il
formato audio libro sono state scelte di
a vendere scene in carica e quelle più
intense e le persone che si sente i
partecipanti a questi 100 partecipanti
sono state misurate la frequenza di
niente l'attività
polemica e la temperatura nulla di
magico e ha fatto vedere queste queste
scene per capire che cosa stava
succedendo
i partecipanti poco spettacolo successe
occhi hanno riferito che secondo loro i
video erano più coinvolgenti quindi
queste persone queste 100 persone e si
sono sottoposte a spendere intorno detto
i video sono stato più coinvolgenti ma
in realtà queste sono delle slide
compresso che serva riprende tantissimo
ma non importa che fanno vedere
non so se riuscite a leggere la musica
game of thrones è una delle serie che
stranieri verso gli istituti e sono
state misurate tre cose attività in
elettrotecnica frequenza cardiaca e
temperatura in verde scendere e il
giallo video come in tutti e tre i casi
gli audiolibri hanno un impatto maggiore
sulla pelle quindi qual è stato concluso
dell'esperimento la condizionale
spendendo è questa le storie sono
cognitivamente ed emotivamente più
coinvolgente evento fisiologico quando
sono presentate formato positivo audio
la voce ascoltarlo e storia piuttosto
quella di via il processo di co
creazione creativo e quindi è più
rilevabile sulla pelle dell'ascoltatore
quindi ho detto si raccomandò video
secondo voi allora
si riprende con l'obiettivo di rinnovare
fino a qui innanzitutto più un audio
tristi perché in altri ma se funziona
nei utile netto di raccontare non
esistono cose universali preposti per
lei però se precedenza la nostra martini
volta insomma da parte dei fan a 1 e noi
adesso stiamo che ascoltiamo progresso
nessuno
attraverso le dissi che cosa succede che
la voce della persona lo stile che sia
programmata di fuori questo che volete
la tradizione che è valso entra
attraverso le cuffie a una dieta link al
cervello si creano sopra di intimità tra
chi parla e di ascolto e attraverso
queste attività si è rodato grazie
[Applauso]